the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie that's foul it's beyond foul
I'll give the Wildings ruling the
leagues have disappeared fastest Illya
speed only something happens to the boys
hmm marries his daughters does he do
with his sons we have to take her with
us when we leave what no it sounds a bit
mad nor does it sound a bit mad it's
impossible the low commander oh you are
sworn to protect that we can't take
please I can still run if after it's
just not possible I'm going to have a
baby if it's a boy
it's a fully booked what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight endgame theories
video I have kind of a crazy tinfoil
idea that I wanted to talk about today
it's not necessarily a theory or
prediction of mine or anything like that
it's really just a thought I had that I
wanted to discuss with all of you today
I want to talk about Craster's Suns the
common belief throughout the fandom is
Christ her sons were turned into the
White Walkers we see today but I want to
propose a different scenario in the game
of thrones television show we meet
crashed her in the second season when
more Commander Mormont leads to the
Nights Watch on a ranging party beyond
the wall
even though crash star is a wildling he
is the closest thing the Nights Watch
has to an ally beyond the wall he allows
the Nights Watch to shack up at his
fortified homestead known as Craster's
keep during their stay this is when we
start to learn some unsavory things
about Craster he lives in his keep with
his daughters and wives once his
daughters are old enough he marries them
and then begins to impregnate them as
often as possible or so it seems when
Jon Snow is told this information he
begins to wonder what Crestor does with
his sons and this eventually leads to a
shocking discovery
[Music]
something say that job
whatever it was I daresay you'll see it
again somehow krasner is able to survive
beyond the wall not only in very harsh
conditions but also at the same time
there have been some disturbing reports
about the White Walkers you see at this
point in the story Mance Rayder is
gathering up as many men as possible as
he prepares to lead an assault on the
wall the wildlings are desperately
wanting to get south of the wall before
winter comes but Craster doesn't seem to
be worried at all in fact he's quite
comfortable where he's at
then we come to find out how that is
even possible one of Craster's daughters
gives birth to a newborn baby boy and
this piques Jon Snow's curiosity because
he knows Crestor is doing something with
his sons in the middle of the night
Crestor leaves his keep and he heads out
into the woods with the baby boy John
follows him into the woods and this is
when he discovers Craster has been
sacrificing his sons to the white
walkers to this day we still don't know
how Craster was able to negotiate this
deal the White Walkers appear to be
leaving Craster and his daughters alone
as long as he keeps supplying them with
his sons but how the hell did Craster
even pull this off the White Walkers do
speak a language in the books known as
Schroth but as far as we know it's not a
language any human can understand
because it only sounds like ice cracking
and breaking the interesting thing is
this isn't the first time babies were
sacrificed to the White Walkers based on
the story old nan used to tell bran it
seems the night's king and queen used to
do something very similar to what
Craster is doing today and there could
possibly be a connection between the two
the night's king and queen reigned for
13 years at the walls oldest castle
known as the night for the Black Gate
leads to north of the wall which is most
likely where the night's king and queen
passed off their sacrifices to the White
Walkers that were beyond the wall it
could be possible that this practice of
sacrificing to the White Walkers was
passed down through generations the
wildling seemed to think the White
Walkers steal their children and there
is a common phrase throughout the north
known as the others take you
if this was a common practice that
started to die out that might explain
why the White Walkers have returned they
were probably getting low on numbers but
now the Craster has been supplying them
when newborn baby boys that could
explain why there are more frequent
sightings of the White Walkers in the
north some people speculate that Craster
is a descendant of the original night's
king and queen people say that he has
black blood annie has a cold smell to
him if Craster has the blood of the
White Walkers that could explain why he
has been sleeping with his daughters as
a way to keep the bloodline pure kind of
like what the Targaryen had done in the
past there are many different theories
about who Craster could be because some
would think the White Walkers must have
some kind of special interest in taking
his baby specifically Craster's father
is also a bit of a mystery all we really
know is Craster's mother was a wobbling
and his father was a man of the Nights
Watch that was stationed at Castle black
but his father's name is never mentioned
so you have to wonder who it could be
some people say his father could be
blood raven and some people say his
father could be maester aemon
both of them did spend many years at
Castle black so if one of these theories
were true that could mean Craster has
Targaryen blood but I've turned you all
away if I wasn't a godly man you were a
godly man when a white cold come his
swords and cloaks and bloody fires won't
help you any one's left will be those
who are right with the guts
the real gods
some could also say that maybe Crestor
is a descendant of one of the Starks the
Starks had been known to man the wall
for thousands of years
so perhaps Craster's father who was in
the Nights Watch could have come from
the Starks bloodline we also know that
house Karstark is a branch of House
Stark and you can trace their descent
from Karlin Stark and through him
to the Starks and the first men now
what's kind of interesting is if you
rearrange some of the letters in
Craster's name you can almost spell the
word Stark but that might be to tinfoil
II for some of you however I would like
to think Craster does come from a
special bloodline because as far as we
know the White Walkers are exclusively
taking his sons when they could be taken
the babies from pretty much anyone they
came across in the north like I said
earlier this would not be the first time
stark children were sacrificed to the
White Walkers because as we all know
according to old nan the original
night's King was a stark of Winterfell
and he was doing the exact same thing as
Craster but what I really want to talk
about is what are the White Walkers in
the night king actually doing with these
babies in season 4 episode 4 we see one
of the White Walkers take rest her son
all the way to the lands of always
winter when he arrives with the baby he
places him on an altar made of ice then
steps in the night king to perform the
ceremony the night king picks up the
baby then he places a finger on his
cheek which changes the baby's eye color
to a icy bright blue the common belief
is the babies are turned into White
Walkers and those are the White Walkers
we see today at least this is what we're
led to believe but how do we know it's
true we have never seen this entire
process unfold do the babies immediately
grow into adult sized White Walkers with
long wispy white hair and wrinkled
booking faces or does this entire
process take time how do we know these
babies aren't still in the far north at
the lanes of always winter until they're
of age and proper size to begin fighting
what if these babies are still in
training to one day take the night Kings
place let's think about what Jon Snow
said to beric Dondarrion in season 7
[Music]
kill him he turned them all
you don't this time when John led the
party beyond the wall to capture a white
they come across a small group of whites
led by a single white Walker when John
killed the white Walker all of the
whites that were under his command fell
at the same time which led beric
Dondarrion to thinkin if you kill the
night king who is their leader then you
can kill them all but Jon Snow did not
automatically agree with this john told
barrack you do not understand which
leads me to believe barracks theory
might not be true this could be
foreshadowing the future of the white
walkers existence
what if killing the night king doesn't
stop them all I mean you have to keep in
mind John does know crashed her sons
were being taken by the white walkers so
maybe he has some suspicions that those
babies are still out there somewhere and
only the old gods know what they had
become maybe this is a part of the
bittersweet ending John and company
could defeat the night king and his army
who came south of the wall but what if
there are still more white Walker babies
in the lands of always winter Craster
allegedly had 99 sons and we've only
seen a handful of White Walkers so there
could very well be many more of them out
there that we have not seen now imagine
if the series ends like this John and
Daenerys defeat the night king and the
army he brought south of the wall Cersei
is no longer on the Iron Throne and
Daenerys is able to have her baby then
at the very end we see Winterfell and
some of the other castles being restored
that would more or less seem like a
sweet ending even if we did lose some of
the other characters we like but at
least we would think most of the evil
has been removed from Westeros until the
very last scene that's when we go inside
the eyes of a raven that's flying beyond
the wall just kind of looking around as
he goes further and further north until
it reaches the lanes of always winter
and as the bird lands it looks down and
we see some a crest her sons who are now
starting to grow into teenagers or
adults then one of them looks up at the
bird and scares it away but those
piercing blue eyes are the last thing we
see before the camera fades to black
that would be pretty damn crazy if you
ask me that sweet ending would not last
for long because then we would know one
day the people of Westeros will have to
face another dangerous threat
from the north I know it might sound
like a ridiculous idea but it was just
something I was thinking about yesterday
so I figured I would talk about it
because I was wondering if any of you
thought something like this was possible
like I said I'm not saying this is my
new theory that I believe will happen at
the end I just wanted to toss around
some different ideas that we usually
don't talk about in the comment section
so let me know what you think put your
thoughts or questions down below anyways
I want to thank everyone for watching
the video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank all of you on patreon
for supporting my channel thank you very
much have a great day I'll see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
you